wer träumt nicht davon einmal im Leben
First Class zu fliegen leider liegen die
Preise dafür schnell bei über 5000 €
manchmal sogar über 10 000 € one way das
ist nicht so zum Tanzen die Emirates
First Class soll eine der besten der
Welt sein und ich freue mich diese für
euch testen zu dürfen wie viel ich dafür
bezahlt habe erfahrt ihr am Ende jetzt
erstmal viel Spaß mit meinem ersten
First Class Test und damit Leute einen
wunderschönen guten Morgen aus Frankfurt
am Main ich bin hier schon am Flughafen
gestern Abend angereist habe jetzt hier
in ein Hotel gepennt weil ja wir haben
jetzt 73 we und mein ich komme mir auch
ein bisschen dumm vor mein Fahrer ist
schon da der mich jetzt abholt und auf
direkten Wege zum Emirates Terminal
bringt ihr habt sicherlich am Titel
schon gelesen wir testen heute und ich
freue mich unfassbar darauf und ich habe
richtig Bock und an dieser Stelle
natürlich auch vielen vielen Dank dass
Sie das möglich macht die Videos so
feiert und ich das machen kann weil es
ist natürlich auch nicht immer alles so
günstig vor einem Jahr hätte ich niemals
gedacht dass ich sowas überhaupt
irgendwann mal in meinem Leben machen
kann aber wir testen heute die Emirates
first class besser geht nicht in einer
Boeing 777 für mich geht's nämlich nach
Dubai ich habe richtig Bock wir müssen
jetzt auch schon los ich bin auf jeden
Fall super gespannt wie ich das ganze
gebucht habe wie teuer es war erfahrt
ihr alles noch und jetzt geht's erstmal
los zum Flughafen 11 Uhr ist mein
Flieger also in dreinhalb Stunden
bisschen Zeit habe ich noch aber ich
wollte bisschen die laouunnge natürlich
abchecken für euch das ganze best
möglich festhalten und ich würde sagen
auschecken und let's go so ab zur
Rezeption sorry übrigens das ist Bild
eben gerade so geflackert hat das hatte
ich noch nie das LAG irgendwie an diesem
komischen Licht da in meinem Hotelzimmer
Frankfurt Airport Alter sind da viele
Taxen Leute ich bin wirklich ein
bisschen nervös ne ich es wir glaub ich
geistesk
geh
sorry dan danke danke nein geht schon
alles
gut jaich
frühlich früh
ja
emat danke fürs Fahren geht schon okay
angekommen am Flughafen war no nur 2 km
ich habe ja auch am Flughafen gepennt
eigentlich direkt und hier geht's jetzt
ins Terminal 2 Emirates ja schauen wir
mal ist auch tatsächlich erst das zweite
Mal dass ich von Frankfurt Fliege letzte
Mal ging es ja nach Thailand so okay
hier habe ich mein Boarding Pass CL
first okay Leute haben Dubai E6 ich ma m
jetzt natürlich auch auf direkten Weg in
die Emirates Lounge wir sind hier in
Frankfurt und es gibt soweit ich weiß
keine reine First Class Lounge das ist
aber eigentlich fast überall normal also
bis und first teilt sich das aber ich
denke es wird trotzdem sehr gut und das
richtige First Class Erlebnis habe ich
dann halt im Flugzeug so priority Lane
da darf ich heute lang sch mal da oben
stehtemat le Lounge und ah hier gibt's
ja viele Lounges na ja Frankfurt ist ja
auch der größte Flughafen in Deutschland
deswegen muss es ja auch so sein ne ich
kann tatsächlich erst in einer Stunde
durch den Security Check weil man darf
sich nur 120 Minuten in diesem Bereich
aufhalten hier hinten sind auf jeden
Fall jetzt die ganzen Lounges könnt auch
hier in diese Prime class loue mit
meinem priority pass aber wir gehen
heute in die Lounge wo ich sonst nicht
immer reinkomme und das
ist die hier hallo guten Morgen herzlich
willkommen
danke
[Musik]
okay Leute ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt
in der Emirates Lounge hier ist auch
wirklich nicht viel los ich bin der
einzige hinter mir sitzt noch zwei und
die Frühstücksauswahl ist wirklich sehr
nice ich denke es wird auch sehr sehr
lecker hier ist es jetzt nicht so dass
man bedient wird sondern man muss sich
das selber nehmen wobei ich glaube dass
ich das ändert wenn es dann Mittagessen
hier gibt und Abendessen eins habe ich
gelernt bei meinem letzten Business
Class Flug nie direkt überfressen
sondern ganz langsam anfangen weil wir
wissen alle in den nächsten 8 ne Stunden
werde ich die ganze Zeit nur essen
ersteer Eindruck von der Lounge ist auf
jeden Fall nicht verkehrt und wir sehen
uns dann gleich wieder das befeh zeige
ich euch noch sofort bis
gleich und so sah das Frühstück aus
Früchte Joghurt alles mögliche dann hier
so Bürstchen bisschen halt typisch
englishch breakfast Rührei alles was man
sich so vorstellt kan aufstr Getränke so
Leute und hier ist die Kaffeeecke sage
ich mal es gibt aber natürlich auch noch
ein paar andere kleine Snacks und hier
die ganzen Spirituosen also man kann
sich auf jeden Fall gut re trinken und
natürlich auch passen für Business und
hier diese champagneecke das ist schon
was besonderes s ich mal gibt jetzt
nicht in anderen loues in die man jetzt
beispielsweise mit dem priority Pass
kommt zumindest in meisten GI nicht das
hier ist die Toilette ja kann man auf
jeden Fall nicht meckern alles in
Ordnung keine Frage man muss aber ganz
klar sagen ich war bis jetzt in einer
vergleichbaren Lounge in Bangkok der
Qatar Airways Lounge bestens und first
und die war deutlich deutlich besser
natürlich aber wir sind halt auch nur in
Frankfurt und ich gehe davon aus dass in
Dubai die laoue schon mal einiges
krasser wird jetzt gleiches Boarding ich
bin so gespannt wir sehen uns okay ich
bin raus aus der Lounge wir haben jetzt
Uhr und mein Gate ist offen das heißt
ich gehe jetzt durch den Security Check
und dann auch direkt ins Flugzeug ich
denke ich kann auch direkt
einsteigen danke schön habe mich dann
zum Checkin begeben und dachte warte mal
als wenn ich mich hier tatsächlich
anstellen muss als First Class Passagier
hier kam mir noch die indonesische
Nationalmannschaft in kegen und dann
habe ich noch mal
gefragt
ja ja komst ir vololl bekannt vor okay
Leute auf geht's in Flieger ich wollte
noch was sagen aber das warte
hi eigentlich dachte ich nämlich dass
man als First Class Reisender also ich
brauch das nicht keine Sorge und so das
dachte ich nur dass das immer so ist
dass man dann einzeln abgeholt wird und
zum Platz begleitet wird aber es könnte
auch sein dass es nur so ist wenn das
Flugzeug weiter wegsheht und nicht
direkt am Geld könnt ihr gerne mal
kommentieren so jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt
[Musik]
hier
no my time
yes
ja only for five days ich hab es mirich
jetzt ein bisschen bequemer gemacht und
was mir aufgefallen ist ich habe
natürlich jetzt auch in letzter Zeit
wirklich meine englischskills noch
richtig verbessern können durch die
ganzen Reisen durch den Austausch mit
Native Speakern oder egal wo ich bin im
Ausland bin ich eigentlich immer auf
meine Englischkenntnisse angewiesen und
klar jeder von uns lernt in der Schule
Englisch aber die Praxis später und die
richtigen Betonung und so weiter und so
fort bekommt man mit reinem
Englischunterricht in Deutschland
natürlich nur schwierig hin da sollte
kte man dann schon mal ein Auslandsjahr
machen wenn ich teilweise an die
bodenlosen Aussprachen in meinem
Englisch Grundkurs zurückdenke da kriege
ich wirklich Gänsehaut das war ganz
unterirdisch aber zum Glück gibt es die
ELSA speakak App die mir auch super
hilft und die ich euch mal eben
vorstellen möchte elsa speakak ist
nämlich die erste englische lenpp die
mit Hilfe modernster künstlicher
Intelligenz die Fehler eurer Aussprache
im englischen direkt erkennt und euch
Feedback gibt wie ihr das verbessern
könnt ich zeig euch natürlich auch
sofort mal wie es funktioniert aber ihr
könnt euch das so vorstellen durch die
KI wird eure Sprache mit der eines
native speakers verglichen und zack
falsch alex hat wieder falsch
ausgesprochen so und so geht's richtig
und irgendwann denkt jedes stewardes
Alter he is from Great Britain els speak
hat mittlerweile mehr als 1600
verschiedene Lektionen und über 40
Themen mit denen du deine englische
Aussprache verbessern kannst du kannst
neues Vokabular lernen du kannst neue
Sätze lernen und das geht ziemlich
einfach so sieht die App aus und wenn
ihr euch ein bisschen damit beschäftigt
könnt ihr auch sozusagen euer eigenes
study Setup zusammenbauen und jeden Tag
dann beispielsweise auch mit
notification von El speakak 10 15 20
Minuten bisschen Englisch lernt ich fand
ganz passend für mein Thema wir sind
jetzt bei Lifestyle und hier gibt's
lessons zu travel meet the
goal meet the
goal
aha
reward
reward reward ah Mist ja jetzt geht's
schon los da steht ja auch in
Lautschrift reward
reward immer noch nicht ganz perfekt
Leute ich denke ich hab verstanden donlo
euch gerne mit dem QRCode das WE ihr
könnt das ganze 7 Tage kostenlos testen
und falls ihr euch dazu entscheidet das
ganze auch länger benutzen zu wollen
könnt ihr über meinen Link in der
Videobeschreibung 40% sparen falls ihr
es lifetime kaufen wollt könnt ihr sogar
85% damit sparen vielen vielen Dank an
els speak dass ihr das Video hier
möglich gemacht habt und wir machen
jetzt weiter hallo
Danke und
Simon oh da muss ich auch
Malin
nein
[Musik]
herzkmen und danke
danke ich muss die ganze Zeit nur
Grenzen we e ist eigentlich so unötig
aber na ja irgendwo auch natürlich
cool jetzt gibt's erstmal ein Champagner
glaube ich falls ich das richtig
verstanden habe es ist für mich so sural
einfach so an so ein Platz zu sitzen wir
so crazy
oh thank
you ja
ja
thanks du yes so Leute auf
euch
10:23 Uhr Zeit für Alkohol man muss den
Bums ja irgendwie aushalten so jetzt
gab's gerade erstmal noch eine Tasche
und
[Musik]
PUs ich bin glau ich wirklich der
einzige hier der heute first fliegt ich
zeig das einmal hier sind die
ganzen Stück gibt ich bin heute einfach
der einzige Gast zumindest bis jetzt und
wenn man weiter hier hinten runter geht
da kommt man dann in die Business
CL
[Musik]
danke
more und ich bekomme auch die ganze Zeit
so Kekse und alles aber ein Tipp von mir
wenn ihr irgendwann mal B oder first
egal wie ob ihr euch das kauft me wie
auch immer genau genießt es aber macht
nicht den Fehler direkt alles zu essen
weil es kommt so viel und dann ist man
direkt überfressen und kann den Rest
nicht mehr essen oder nicht mehr
genießen also keine Sorge dass ihr nicht
auf die Kosten kommt wenn ihr nicht
direkt voll reinhaut sondern ganz
entspannt angehen
[Applaus]
lassen Leute wir haben leider eine
Verspätung von 25 Minuten aber jetzt
geht's so langsam los Flugzeit ist wohl
auch nur 5 Stunden 30 und nicht 6
Stunden 15 wie auf meinem Ticket stand
aber na ja ich will mich gar nicht
beschweren also ist natürlich kein
langen langen Streckenflug aber ich
glaube so nach Dubai kann man schon auch
als Langstrecke bezeichnen genau ich bin
gespannt wie es weitergeht ich glaube es
wird auf jeden Fall noch sehr crazy ich
muss sagen auf der einen Seite fühlt man
sich natürlich ein bisschen ja weil du
wirst halt wirklich alle Z Minuten
gefragt ob du irgendwas haben willst das
ist natürlich nur nett gemeint ich kann
auch verstehen dass Leute sagen die
nervt es dann irgendwann mich nervt es
nicht ich genieße das einfach und jetzt
heißt es erstmal
takeoff
okay und dann ging es auch schon los mir
wurd erstmal das Menü oder die Menükarte
serviert da muss ich schon Grinsen die
war sehr umfangreich und natürlich auch
eine Weinkarte mit ziemlich vielen
verschiedenen Weinen und die schauen wir
uns dann jetzt mal zusammen an so wie
ihr sehen könnt wurde jetzt gerade auch
schon h mein Bett gemacht damit ich es
noch bequemer hab ich könnte auch so ein
Pyjama anziehen aber habe ich gesagt wir
haben halt jetzt 11 Uhr brauche ich gar
nicht und jetzt schauen wir mal was es
hier gleich schönes leckeres zu Essen
gibt ich bin total überfundt mit dem
ganzen ey hier gibt's Cavia ich habe
noch nie in meinem Leben Cavia probiert
also leute schaut euch mal diese
Geisteskranke Karte an Cavia als
Vorspeise und ich nehme glaube ich das
pan fried beef Filet Dessert auch E
wirkich einfach krass und hier haben wir
noch die Weinkarte ja ich glaube ich bin
auf jeden Fall besoffen wenn ich später
in Dubai ankomme und ich muss auf jeden
Fall auch ein Bier trinken weil ihr
wisst ja ich trinke immer Bier und es
gibt auch so sweets die kannst du halt
die ganze Zeit bestellen Snacks
Popcorn
yes thank you er meinte ich muss die
ganze Flasche alleine trinken weil ich
der einzige ich habe glaube ich auch
noch nie meinem Leben Don Peron
getrunken nicht meinem od eben war es W
jetzt ist es Don Peron Leute Cheers auf
euch würde ich mir niemals privat kaufen
oder trinken weil ich jetzt auch nicht
so abfeier aber Augen zu
[Musik]
durch
tschüss so jetzt gab's erstmal ein
Geschenk das hier ist so eine mir fällt
der Name nicht ein auf jeden Fall ist
hier einiges drin ich weiß gar nicht was
ich euch alles zeigen soll zuerst ich
muss euch noch so viel zeigen wo ist
eigentlich mein Rucksack oh den haben
die irgendwo verstaut da ich der einzige
First Class Passagier war konnte mein
Rucksack auch in Einzel Platz ergattern
in der anderen First Class Kabine
nebenan ich glaube weil ich hier da
Einzug bin haben sich als Aufgabe
gesetzt nicht
abzufüllen
ich befinde mich jetzt gerade hier auf
der Toilette ich muss sagen natürlich ja
alles ein bisschen luxuriöser als sonst
in der Economy oder irgendwelchen
Kurzstrecken Flügen aber ich habe auch
schon auf Videos noch krassere und
deutlich größere Emirates First Class
Toiletten gesehen keine Ahnung warum
diese jetzt hier eher klein gehalten ist
ist mir natürlich scheißegal aber man
muss es hier ansprechen ne und was ich
aber ganz cout finde das WD mir auch
geschrieben von euch hier gibt es das
amace Parfüm was wohl sehr sehr gut sein
soll und das bekomme ich auch geschenkt
hat wohl ein Wert von 60 € falls ich da
jetzt richtig liege hier testen wir no
mal ja man muss ja auch immer gut
riechen ne so und Tschüss okay hier kann
ich zumachen damit ich meinen komplett
eigenen Bereich habe wir sind jetzt auf
jeden Fall ungefähr seit ein halben
Stunde unterwegs jetzt gleich kann ich
essen bestellen die Karte ist wirklich
geisteskrank bevor wir uns darauf
konzentrieren schauen wir uns mal die
Kabine ein bisschen genauer
an also hier das kann ich gerade nicht
hochfahren weil hier zu viele Sachen
liegen hier stehen so ein paar
wassersachen und soweit alles kann man
alles Trinken ist natürlich alles
undsonst ist ja auch klar bei dem Preis
hier haben wir so einen kleinen
süßigkeitenkorb man kann ja auch Popcorn
bestellen airpod sind hier drin ne spaß
das sind meine hier haben wir so das ist
irgendwie Schokolade Smarties Indian
Masala
Mix Schokolade irgendwelche anderen
Bonbons ich will das gar nicht alles
probieren sonst wir mir wieder schlecht
vielleicht probieren wir später davon
noch was aber jeder von euch hat ja
sicherlich schon mal smartis probiert
schön zu haben braucht man jetzt nicht
zwingend hier habe ich sogar eine Blume
die ist hier mit bei mir im ab Teil drin
was mir viele von euch schon bei
Instagram geschrieben haben ich poste
auch immer meine ganzen Reisen und wenn
ich irgendwi unterwegs bin vorsichtig
vielleicht FT das noch um das hier ist
jetzt das ich hoffe ich spreche es
richtig aus M Ticket das ist ganz geil
mir wird das geschenkt ist im Preis mit
enthalten und ja ich brauche e eine neue
Kulturtasche deswegen freue ich mich da
sehr drüber und ich habe es euch gerade
schon auf der Toilette gezeigt wobei das
Parfüm nicht das gleiche war wie hier
hier ist wohl Parfüm drin genau das doch
das war das gleiche das kostet wohl 60 €
und was haben wir hier noch bei
aserschaum hydration body lauschen ach
so es ist ein das ist auch wieder ein
Handtuch everyates vielen vielen Dank
basteln wir das mal wieder zusammen das
ist natürlich noch nicht alles
Moment rasiererschau von Gilette oh
sogar den neuen Gilet Dingsbums der ist
doch immer influencer Werbung hier ach
so ich habe gerade vergessen zu sagen ja
hier haben wir jetzt die zahnbü ihr
könnt mir gerne bei insta folgen da
poste ich die ganzen Reisen immer auch
ein paar Fotos so dann bekommt ihr das
im vorhinin schon mit heiß ich Alex wie
genauso könnt ihr natürlich auf Youtube
hier ein Abo da lassen wenn ihr das
feiert und vielen vielen Dank für den
Support auf die letzten Videos da freue
ich mich echt richtig Dr drüber ich habe
echt wieder richtig Spaß in Youtube kann
man ja auch verstehen wenn man sich das
anguckt wobei ich eben schon gesagt habe
ein bisschen schämt man sich auch so zu
reisen weil es ist halt einfach unnötig
Rexona shower fresh und Tempos ja das
war's dann auch ich denke mal das ganze
Ding hat so ein Gesamtwert von Schätzen
100 bis 150 € mit diesem ja schon schön
ist schön zu haben und vielen vielen
Dank was kann ich euch noch zeigen wir
haben hier neues kceling Kopfhörer
Bowers and Wilkins wirklich sehr sehr
tolle Kopfhörer muss man einfach sagen
habe ich jetzt gar nicht verwendet weil
ich habe meine airpods drin aber ich
werde mir gleich noch ein Film
reinziehen und dann kommen die natürlich
auch zur Anwendung okay dann schauen wir
uns noch mal kurz hier die Kabine ein
bisschen genauer an hier habe ich noch
den Pyjama bekommen den ich aber jetzt
erstmal nicht anziehen werde der
Unterschied hier zu Business ist
natürlich dass man viel mehr Platz hat
man hat auch seine Privatsphäre kann das
ganze hier zu machen das kann man in der
Business classe jetzt gerade nicht muss
sagen ich bin auch mal super gespannt
auf Qatar Airways First Class werde ich
bestimmt auch ja spätestens nächstes
Jahr irgendwann noch machen und hier
haben wir dann für unsere Ladies so ein
kleinen Schminktisch mit ebenfalls als
irgendwelchen komischen gesichtsf
Produkten was weiß ich hier haben wir
dann noch so ein Block hier kann ich ein
paar Sachen einstellen z.B auch Service
rufen oder was weiß ich und hier kann
ich dann noch meinen Sitz in die
essensposition bringen zum Bett machen
oder wie auch immer ich glaube das
müsste es dann auch eigentlich schon
gewesen sein falls ich noch irgendwas
finde melde ich mich natürlich damit und
ich werde dann jetzt auch Zeit nach
Essen bestellen mir wurd eben gesagt jo
wenn was ist wenn du irgendwas brauchst
es ist ganz egal was was auch immer du
trinken willst uns du kannst trinken bis
du umfällst du kannst das ganze Flugzeug
leer trinken also so wurd es mir
wirklich gesagt Leute wirklich vielen
Dank an dieser Stelle noch mal dass ich
diesen Luxus einmal genießen darf auch
wenn man es nicht braucht ich brauch es
überhaupt nicht aber ich freue mich
natürlich das testen zu dürfen und
daraus so ein cooles Video zu machen ich
checke jetzt einmal aus wie das ist wenn
ich mich in die Waagerechte lege schaut
mal machen wir hier mal eben noch
zu so verrückt und da ist einfach auch
noch ein Spiegel hallo e wow es ist
einfach nur crazy man hat so unfassbar
viel Platz und ich ich weiß es gibt
Airlines da hat man noch eine heftigere
First Class also zumindest vom Platz her
es gibt ja diese Singapore First Class
SED das ist ja einfach geisteskrank
Pyjama und das hier ist mein Oberteil
wenn ich jetzt schon hierm reise ich
zieh es mal
an so meine Hose lasse ich aber an also
da kann man wirklich nicht meckern ne es
ist boah das Bett ist so brutal geil ich
weiß nicht was ich sagen soll ich bin ja
hier jetzt gerade in der Boeing 777 und
soweit ich mich erinnern kann gibt's in
der Flotte von Emirates auch den Airbus
A380 und dort gibt es in der First Class
sogar Duschen das heißt ich könnte jetzt
einfach Duschen aber gut muss ich jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt dafür ist hier die
Kabine wohl ein bisschen besser und noch
ein Unterschied im A380 von Emirates
gibt es auch diese Skybar wo man
wirklich dann Getränke bestellen kann
Cocktails und so weiter kommt ja auch in
super vielen Hollywood Film und soofor
das gibt's hier ebenfalls nicht aber ist
mir egal weil ich habe hier trotzdem den
geilsten Seat 1A und ich bin einfach nur
geflasht eigentlich fehlen mir die Worte
aber ich versuch es natürlich best
möglich für euch zusammenzufassen und
jetzt wird Essen bestellt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so Tisch ist gemacht jetzt gibt's Essen
ich habe entlich was
bestellt thank
you
so
okay ich hat genommen sorry Mama wenn du
das siehst tut mir leid nee kein
champanne no no no no oh Tiger tigerbeer
ja you like it
ich danke danke
[Musik]
danke oh
okayod
will no
okay
wunderbar danke
danke so Leute Pavia ist weg und jetzt
muss ich e noch runter
spülen
[Musik]
wow ehrlicherweise bin ich jetzt sogar
schon eigentlich fast satt und der
Hauptgang ist noch nicht malr da
Nachtisch auch nicht das ist das war das
was ich euch eben gesagt habe
supere brutal Hammer so Leute so langsam
werde ich auch ein bisschen müde ich
habe jetzt mein hauptkamp auch eine
Stunde später verschoben und machen m
jetzt erstmal hier ein bisschen lang ich
bin halt erst um 2 Uhr eingepennt und
bin um hal3r aufgestanden also hab jetzt
nicht so viel sch bekommen ich merke ger
dass ich müde werde deswegen Ruh ich mir
jetzt kurz aus okay Leute Hauptgang ist
serviert es ist gerade sehr wacklig und
ich habe Angst dass die Cola gleichfällt
aber nein aber es wird irgendwie ein
bisschen turvalent
gerade okay Sound g ah red oh
Leute guten
Appetit
yes auch sehr lecker aber ich habe schon
besseren aber ich will gar nicht meh wir
sind auch
Flugzeug
[Musik]
ach so haben wir noch ein bisschen
Schokolade drin also Leute habt's gehört
das ist laut ihm hier wohl die
schlechteste first class in
Anführungsstrichen genau im A380 soll
die First Class ähnlich sein es gibt
halt noch eine Dusche und in den neueren
Boeing 777 ist sie noch geräumiger und
wohl noch luxuriöser na habe ich wohl
Pech gehabt dass ich hier gelandet bin
aber ich will mich gar nicht beschweren
alles gut und Leute was auch ganz geil
ist das gab es bei anderen Airlines
nicht man kann hier wirklich live TV
gucken hier läuft das gerade irgendwie
Cricket aber ich kann auch z.B BBC News
schauen ist halt geil wenn wirklich
irgendwie Champions League läuft damit
Wirt emates auch dass man das dann
unterwegs schauen kann das wäre für mich
schon ein Grund mehr auch tatsächlich
dann ja wieder mit emates zu fliegen
weil zumindest wenn Dortmund Spiel und
wir haben jetzt auch nur noch eine
Stunde 30 dann werde ich schon in Dubai
landen ich merk es auch schon so langsam
es wird dunkel draußen also in Dubai ist
es jetzt schon dunkel und ich fliege
jetzt gleich in die Dunkelheit rein die
6 Stunden gehen auf jeden Fall
rasendchnell um also ist was ganz
anderes als wenn man irgendwie economy
fliegt
natürlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
scheiße ist alles
[Musik]
runtergefallen
okay leuteus geht bisschen traurig aber
na ja
okay okay Leute ich bin da erstes Mal in
meinem Leben in Dubai ich freue mich
echt sehr das sah ger aus dem Flieger
schon sehr imposant aus schauen wir mal
wie mir das hier gefällt schöne Grüße
noch mal an Simon bester Flugbegleiter
so nett wirklich best greetings Simon
doing great job hope to see you again if
you see it ich weiß nicht was ich sagen
soll mir fehlen ein bisschen die Worte
das war wirklich ein Geisteskranker Flug
und das muss man erlebt haben um es so
beschreiben zu können aber wir sehen uns
später im Hotel ich muss jetzt erstmal
dahinfahren dann kann ich euch noch ein
bisschen mehr sagen so Leute ich habe
jetzt so eine Nummer bekommen und damit
kann ich jetzt anscheinend zu meinem
Hotel fahren also falls das jetzt
einfach so klappt ist das echt stark
organisiert das muss man
sagen ja also optimal kann man nicht
meckern hat gut
[Musik]
geklappt so Leute das ist mein Hel es
4000 km hoch thanks bye bye Alter ist
das Hoch angekommen im Hotel und ich
habe irgendwie direkt so ein Upgrade
bekommen habe nur 100 € bezahlt aber
hatte eine riesen Suite also das Zimmer
war echt gewaltig groß ich frage mich
wer wirklich alleine so große
zimmerbucht das braucht man doch gar
nicht am nächsten Tag sah so aus und
dann bin ich umgezogen ich bin noch mal
umgezogen und wir befinden uns jetzt
schon im zweiten Hotel hier das davor
war zwar eigentlich besser aber jetzt
befinde ich mich auf dieser Palme ich
blende euch mal ein Foto ein und H habe
ich auch direkte Aussicht aufs Meer es
wird aber auf jeden Fall auch noch ein
Video aus Dubai kommen da zeige ich euch
das dann mal und ja fahrt ihr auch was
ich so von Dubai halte jetzt aber noch
kurz das Fazit und Schlusswort zu meinem
ersten First Class Flug mit Emirates ein
Satz beschreibt es denke ich ganz gut
braucht man das nein es ist trotzdem
geil und macht Spaß ja es war auf jeden
Fall eine unfassbar krasse Erfahrung und
ich habe jede Minute an Bord genossen
toller Flug sehr entspannt angekommen
viel zu viel gegessen getrunken ging
eigentlich weil irgendwann habe ich
gesagt okay ich möchte keinen Champagne
mehr bitte für den Preis den ich jetzt
bezahlt habe würde ich es auf gar keinen
Fall noch mal machen Business Class ist
wirklich ein krasses Update zu economy
man kann viel entspannter reisen kommt
viel spannter an man startet eigentlich
schon in den Urlaub mit Urlaub im
Flugzeug aber bis auf diesen
brilllianten Service und eine noch mal
deutlich größere eigene Kabine und
dascheidet sich die First Class
eigentlich kaum von der Business Class
den Flug habe ich nicht mit mein oder so
bezahlt ich habe Business Class hin und
zurück gebucht das hat mich 3400 €
gekostet ist schon eine Ansage und geht
mit anderen Airlines auch günstiger
Emirates bewegt sich allerdings schon so
zwischen 3 und 5000 € hin und zurück von
Frankfurt nach Dubai doppelt so lange
Strecke beispielsweise dann nach Bangkok
ebenfalls mit emates kostet aber das
gleiche also diese Strecke ist einfach
nur teuer und ich ich konnte mein
Hinflug dann ein Tag vorher für 1270 €
noch mal upgraden somit hat mich also
der reine Hinflug rund 3000 € gekostet
was für ein so ein Flug verdammt viel
Geld ist anders ging es nicht auch die
meen die ich sonst alternativ einlösen
hätte können waren ziemlich hoch genau
und für die es wissen wollen wenn man
nur diesen einzelnen First Class Flug
hin nach Dubai gebucht hätte hätte ich
5500 € sogar bezahlt also falls ich noch
mal First Class pliege auf jeden Fall
nur mit meinen irgendwie rumtricken
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen wir fliegen
Business Class mit
ja zurück da wird's dann auch noch Video
zu geben und wir schauen mal wie gut ist
das eigentlich und ich bin mal gespannt
ob die Emirates Business Class mit der
von Qatar mithalten kann vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen abonniert sehr gerne den
Kanal für weitere Reise Videos hier geht
jetzt um 17:30 Uhr schon die Sonne unter
es ist gleich dunkel haut rein Leute
ciao